seriously Logan is more than 160 years
old every romantic encounter he has in
these movies is now officially creepy
but still not as creepy as Edward
Collins
now let's cross the border and fight in
every major American war for the next
hundred years during this opening credit
sequence we see Logan and Victor
surviving shots to the chest while
kicking all sorts of ass in every war
imaginable and their legendary story
somehow doesn't spread throughout the
world also I understand he was probably
angry in Ford but did he have to fight
in every single war in history that
wasn't even one war where he was like
now you guys I'm sitting this one out
also Spielberg saw this opening sequence
and immediately said I want to make the
horse version of this okay so they were
surrounded but so fucking what they're
invincible no one can hurt them so why
don't they run away or do they know that
shredders gonna offer them a special ops
job once they're thrown in jail movie
rips off the evil mentor recruits the
hero while he's in prison thing from
Batman Begins I'm having blade Trinity
flashbacks and he didn't even use a
sword in that movie I'm not saying this
mission calls for them to be more covert
I'm just saying that even if they
weren't on a particular mission since
they're in Nigeria it might behoove them
to be a little more covert in general
why are we here all in good time you
really need to be kept in the dark that
we're looking for this super rare
indestructible metal we don't want the
fanboys blowing their watch just yet
also Logan wants to know what the
mission is but only seconds before it
begins
it takes these assholes forever to spot
a team of almost all white mercenaries
casually standing outside their heavily
guarded gate
movie rips off the guy pretends to
surrender by lifting his arms but then
pulls a secret gun from his back thing
from every action film that came out
after die heart
we interrupt this Wolverine movie to
bring you Hit Girl the tank viewfinder
shows you what you'd see if you were
literally looking down the barrel never
mind all the loud gunfire that happened
a minute ago
it's the explosion that finally gets
these people to notice something is
wrong
hilarious ironic music cliche thank you
sir you look really nice today I feel
bad for Ryan Reynolds because he's tight
cast as Van Wilder in every movie no
matter the genre bad guy henchmen line
up in a formation that ensures the
camera can still clearly see their boss
but that in reality would get several of
them shot by the men behind them also
the boss is completely unprotected
this is just a terrible formation all
around okay dad really
were they bloodless people so it's at
this point that I wonder weirds Victor
in all this we saw him climb the top of
the building and we saw him laugh at
murder from the roof but he didn't help
one bit and he loves killing people and
not once does he show back up in the
scene how exactly does word get out two
secret military guys that the African
diamond Lord has a rock in his
possession that he merely considers a
souvenir it's not like he's bragging
about it or using it in any special way
the thing is a paperweight
to be fair you didn't sign up for
anything you were given the option to be
in this special team or be in jail also
we didn't sign up for this cliche the
weather knows something dramatic just
happened here's something we probably
didn't need an entire origins movie to
know sensitive Logan is boring oh she's
a goner discount Michelle Williams this
is always dumb to do especially for a
carnival prize there's no way the paper
got this picture of Chris unless he's
got eight-by-ten glossies of him looking
exactly the way he did when we first saw
him also circus freak that's harsh how
about Hobbit cheek also this is being
considered a regular old murder and not
like a wild animal got loose and mauled
the guy to death also the second article
in this paper is how local residents are
unhappy with the cops for not finding
the killer sooner strange considering it
just happened recently enough for there
to be a big headline about it aka last
night wow it's a good thing that Logan
and Kayla switched up who got to keep
the car today or else he couldn't have
left in a huff like this earlier she got
to keep the car which made sense because
she's a schoolteacher and probably has a
shorter day she's not home
right after she says this of course
there are assholes blocking the road for
no damn reason other than to put these
words to the test in some kind of a
hurry they're Pompeii I get it this
characters an asshole but do you need to
be in a hurry to be upset about this
situation I mean I could be in no hurry
wanna punch this guy the writers needed
a flimsy conflict here for some reason
and the best they could come up with was
to Canadian Bros blocking the road with
her trucks who won't let Logan pass
because they're having a conversation
I know it's Canada but Jesus in every
night he looks up in the sky and sees
the moon and the house her name Jesus we
already know his girlfriend was gonna
die anyway but now this story's like a
double whammy she'll probably die in the
next scene means the Wolverine roll
credits
Logan can smell Victor only when it's
way too late to do anything about it
at least in this situation maybe I won't
care that this chick is dead if the
screenwriters had given her any more
character development than just chick
Logan is fucking no cliche also and
that's the original Wolverine screaming
to the heavens when his girlfriend
tragically dies why why that is funny
isn't this the most pointless fight ever
aren't they both super-strong with super
healing abilities did they just like
getting tired here's another asshole
truck driver not stopping or even
slowing down after hitting a body with
his windshield
I am truly confused at Victor's
motivations he seems to be mad that
Logan left the mercenary group and got a
girlfriend and that Logan doesn't want
to kill humans and while that's maybe
enough to cause a brotherly argument is
it really enough to justify a killing
spree maybe we should have started with
x-men origins Victor we're gonna make
you indestructible but first we're gonna
have to destroy our hunt also who
volunteers for an experimental procedure
the only details of which they possess
is that it will be the most painful
thing ever no questions asked at all
until he strapped on the fucking table
to kill him gonna have to embrace the
other side and find a cure for
invincibility I want new ones do you
want them to say Wolverine roll credits
yeah definitely roll credits did you
just pause everything and go stamp these
new dog tags and then get the procedure
underway
oh man I thought Wolverine was a goner
for sure scene does not contain a
Wolverine style lap dance you know for
the ladies oh I thought for sure I would
have worked on the guy who's been taking
bullets the whole movie some of my sons
I love clothes will probably fit because
my son lived here until he became
Wolverine sized and then left to pursue
a career on Wall Street I know I'm an
asshole but didn't they code his bones
with adamantium so those bone claws were
not smooth and sharp like knife blades
before they were coated with metal but
after also and I'm really stepping into
nitpicking asshole territory here
there's no way these claws
fit inside his forearm whenever they're
not extended also cartoon Klaus is only
rehash of dumb moon story is rehashed
they're taking the bike for a spin
you'll need it for the convenient escape
later what connects is in the barn is
just murdered two civilians blow him to
bits I suppose we're about to learn they
put some sort of tracking device on him
during that surgery or put it in his dog
tags or something right this is the 70s
right now the fuck are they transmitting
video of this chase well shooting didn't
work last time let's shoot him again
also not that it matters but these are
the most expert marksmen in the world
and can't hit Wolverine or the
motorcycle
how did alpha 1 ever find him Wolverine
randomly sped out of the bar on a
motorcycle into a random part of the
woods and came out of a random section
of it there's an army vehicle just
driving around in case that happened
shoot a missile he's seriously taunting
Wolverine at this moment for real the
helicopter spilled a perfect trail of
fuel so that Wolverine could do this
walking away from the fireball cliche
also Wolverine screen saver never stood
a chance
but this gun will do what every gun in
history couldn't donate seen it'll take
him down I sent adamantium bullet that's
why I only made six of them also you
just pumped his body full of adamantium
and and he's invincible how stupid is
this anyway
the young mutant you've been looking for
we found him doesn't matter how that
it's easy finding mutants child's play
that's why Professor X has to put on a
helmet and use a giant Epcot Center golf
ball computer to find them also in this
case you're talking about cyclops who if
you knew about him and were therefore
looking for him is a kid in high school
and isn't hiding anywhere so once you
first heard about him he should have
been easy to find
less later myself couldn't take relative
up John placed the pronoun game so that
Wolverine has to ask who the hell he's
talking about
we heard a tone con Logan where was
Professor X and cerebro during all this
surely he could have seen the mutants
killing each other and want to do
something about it just what this movie
needed fat bastard so even a stretch
oblique enough to take this guy out of
here they on the stretch
well Wolverine it's made of adamantium
so there's no suspense where this scene
is going this movie expects me to
believe that a note-taking Wolverine is
going to put on boxing gloves and have
playtime with someone he's interrogating
did these hookers even read a comic book
before writing this thing
the only reason Stryker is at this
school so we can have a cool scene where
we find out he's working with Victor
it's not like he was needed in order to
capture this kid it's not like Victor
wasn't hunting mutants on his own the
entire rest of the movie
what's the island multiple choice answer
is it a one of the more Forgotten
Michael Bay movies from the 2000s
compared to the rest of his body of work
it's not a bad little film is it B
definitely not whatever Sean Bean told
you it was is it C a landmass completely
surrounded by water or D all of the
above
what's the island it's for Streicher
takes him after Victor's caught him they
must teach the pronoun game to these
guys they take food Logan really should
know what Fred is talking about despite
his insistence on playing the pronoun
game John told him about how he used to
round up mutants five minutes ago
let's try corrupt you frame what's the
endgame it's taking their powers how do
you know this all of a sudden you just
said some people say he's doing
experiments on them there the rumor is
that strikers doing experiments on them
they're coming with you Logan there's no
redemption where I'm going
I'm coming with you and you can't stop
me cliche miss Bourbon Street scene does
not contain a Mardi Gras the escaped
prisoner they're looking for is in the
first place they look in New Orleans
also if you were put on an island prison
where they did experiments on you and
stuff would you just go back home and be
this easy to find also no one would ever
play poker with a guy who can do this
kind of stuff with cards especially not
Daniel Negreanu or even a character
played by Daniel Negreanu shit done
could be imma kill you with what you
know this guy's practically invincible
right you're gonna punch him to death
I'm calling bullshit on this fight right
here Victor just senses where this guy
is gonna pop up next he wins not by
strength or fingernails or superpowers
just good guesswork and it's not
forgiving just because you have Victor
say you're predictable right afterwards
either wait this asshole ran back two
blocks away from the fight just so he
could jump up on the roof and run and do
this jump thing he did it does what you
did to her then do it already
gambit chases after Wolverine because he
stupidly thinks that he wants to take
him back to the island but he allows
Victor to run away a man he should know
extremely well and will want to kill
Wolverine is a dick to fire escapes
man the NLO PD really doesn't give a
shit do they this is between Bourbon
Street we still haven't seen one cop
investigate the dude who got thrown
through the wall at a jazz club so
you're gonna take me to this island or I
can kill Creed Stryker and pretty much
everyone you hate in this world you
could have helped me kill create a
minute ago but you decided very stupidly
that I was the bad guy in this situation
cool evil that is evil scene but he said
we know about your son it's not like a
problem was solved other people also
know it's not like no one will miss the
4-star general but whatever evil guy is
evil your powers for the pool the script
just hit a world record for having a
character see something being that
requires the other character to ask what
the hell they mean my son was the first
piece of the puzzle
Logan you were the last well know
Cyclops was you kidnapped him after you
gave Wolverine his adamantium and he
escaped the facility also let's talk
about strikers plan he wants to locate
dangerous mutants and create Deadpool a
controllable super mutant with the
strengths of all those mutants but
aren't Logan and Victor already pretty
damned indestructible on their own but
on all the other mutant powers and even
without the adamantium I've learned that
nothing motivates the men in your family
like revenge
Caitlyn do exactly the time to show up
in order for this to be dramatic it gave
me a shot of hydrochloric
a drug that in no way can make healthy
people appear dead but that's not
important right now
did you know that her sister has
diamond-hard skin
now we're know we've seen this is Emma
Frost but we're strongly implying it and
it makes the Emma Frost appearance in
x-men first class all the more head
scratching by Helen the moon over the
tracks charge so then it would be the
moon in the story well now that I know
the truth about Kayla go ahead and keep
creating your super mutant that kills
other mutants Stryker I won't get in the
way mind games don't work on me but why
that ought to hold him activate Weapon
11 bombing process is the bonding
process isn't complete yet cliche I
can't say I know a lot about Deadpool in
the comics but I can say that every
Deadpool fan I know hates this movie for
what they did a Deadpool are diamonds
bulletproof Jesus we're still in the 70s
here right pristine quality video from
rotatable security cameras displayed via
a custom software interface the fuck
wait what Deadpool kick Wolverine out of
the warehouse here and then we cut to
Kayla and now suddenly Wolverine as this
giant fucking head start up the
smokestack Professor X montina also
Charles waits until after Cyclops has
captured thrown in prison and begins to
escape to finally talk to it why does
Deadpool even bother with punching and
kicking when he has swords and Cyclops
power also sure he can teleport but guys
there are only two places he can stand
and attack you from just start flailing
your claws in front of you and you win
his brain may heal his memories will
grow back well that certainly sounds
scientific so I'm inclined to trust you
on this one this doesn't change anything
between us Victor except the part about
how I came here to cut your head off and
ended up saving your life helping you up
and generally brewing out with you in
the last 10 minutes the fuck is this
asshole bin he got here just in time to
be useless it's not like Wolverine is
gonna die from falling debris or
anything also what would splitting the
piece of smokestack in half actually do
there would still be rubble that should
hit Logan considering how close it was
to hitting it instead not even anything
that amounts to gravel comes down on his
head I guess that second bullet is for
cyclopses memory as well that wouldn't
make us know better
you that would make us no better than
them cliche this is the movie saying
yeah all that book that you just saw is
actually Canon somehow and also funhouse
face Patrick Stewart you're safe god
knows what I would have done without
Wolverine looking for his revenge and
breaking you out of here or why I
allowed this to happen in the first
place but everyone get on the helicopter
also how does everyone fit on this
helicopter anyway can't quite put my
finger on what's wrong with the scene of
mutants running towards Xavier and his
helicopter but it might be that
everything in it looks fake ooh good
thing for Stryker that memory loss
guests turned out to be accurate both
mid-credits villain gets his comeuppance
scene two end credits scenes Jesus this
movie really thinks highly of itself
doesn't it I've got to admit this was no
surprise at all destroy I'm Batman
[Music]
come back they come vengeance to
becoming wrath oh it's just what they'll
be expecting mr. sorry
I farted give me Willie the girl was a
zygote when you were in the seventh
grade we're gonna make you
indestructible first I have to destroy
we can rebuild him we have the
technology we have the capability to
make the world's first Bionic man
what happened way to go go get a Peter
Pan right here for this damn right here
what's the island we have to go back
Kate
we have to go back relax
[Music]
there it is
tell me mr. Anderson what good is a
phone call if you're unable to speak
nobody kills you but maybe the brothers
don't shake hands
brothers got up were the other drugs
[Music]